Speaker 1: Let's go next to Connor from
New Jersey. Connor from New Jersey.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Oh, well, hey, David. I've talked
to you a couple of times already. Appreciate
you having me on the show again. I love it.
So I remember I called you a while back. I saw a
video. You did? Where? We did, like a snippet of
our conversation where I really didn't elaborate
on what I was going on about with me coming from
a conservative space. But again, last time was
for me to say thank you for what you do. And, you
know, I really find you inspiring. But let's move
on from that, please. Let's try to address like
where I'm coming from and like, this weird mix
where I see myself as, like, socially conservative
and politically progressive, right? Mm hmm. So I
explain to you that, like, I'm for gay marriage. I
support the idea of LGBT rights, and you know that
we should be able to see humans as humans and not
say like, Oh, you're living the delusion. People
should be able to at least live their lives to
the fullest capabilities. So where I think that I
might lean more towards like a more right leaning
take is I'm for a free market to a degree. Right.
I like the idea of small businesses being able to
freely compete amongst one another. But where
I might be more progressive is when it comes to
corporations. I feel like for them to operate in
a free market leads to small businesses not being
able to operate freely as they would want to be.
And my issue with corporations operating freely
is they have a tendency to smash any ability
for small businesses to really freely operate.
And my argument for this is like, let's see at the
small mom and pop shop, those shops went away when
something like Walmart came in, which had much
further stock, had the ability to outcompete in
terms of products that they could sell. They had a
much larger net worth than these small businesses.
A lot of them would end up being bought up because
they just would perceive the money and be like,
Well, why am I going to continue to struggle
against Walmart if I'm getting this money?
Speaker 1: I just can't. I'm
not sure I really understand.
So you're saying on the one hand, let me see if
I can understand the positions you've outlined.
You told me you're left wing on gay marriage
and you are progressive on corporations. To
the extent that larger companies scoop up or put
out of business mom and pops. But you're generally
speaking for a free market and low business
regulation, which makes you economically right
wing. My understanding, the position is correct.
Speaker 2: So I want the smaller businesses to
be able to operate more freely. But I think
larger corporations should be regulated to
prevent them from corporate monopolies being
able to do things like abuse offshore workers.
I mean, a fine example would be in the
technological industries we use in the U.S. I've
learned it's not the same case for other countries
like Germany, but in the U.S., there's a lot of
slave labor that takes place outside of the United
States. Yeah. The Congo would be a great example
of that. And my whole point is more regulation I
think needs to be accomplished in order for things
like that to not be allowed of U.S. corporations.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, it's really not there's un
let me I'll give you two answers in what you're
telling me. There is a bit of a contradiction in
the sense that you're sort of espousing different
views about your expectations of government,
depending on which issue we're talking about.
Like, for example, you support LGBT rights,
but you're against governments regulating
businesses, businesses that might discriminate
against LGBT people. No, but hold on. I'm not
saying you said that. I'm just saying that's a
way in which there might be a contradiction.
But let me zoom out to the bigger picture.
In my view, saying that as a corporation, once
you've reached a certain size, there might be
additional regulations placed on you. I agree
with that. And I think that right now that's a
fundamentally left wing economic perspective.
Speaker 2: And I don't claim to be educated
on this stuff, but I was trying to explain
like, you know, I'm still for small businesses
being able to do what they want, but in a more
progressive stance, I don't think corporations
should be able to do what they want.
Speaker 1: Considering by corporations
you mean large corporations, right? Because
small businesses might also be a corporation.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Corporate monopolies,
I think is what I'm really trying to
get is operations that are clearly.
Speaker 1: Relatively left wing to
me. I mean, I'm not hearing anything
definitively right wing in there.
Speaker 2: Well, again, I like capitalism.
I'm not someone that thinks that capitalism
is inherently evil. Yeah, just remember that.
Speaker 1: Social democracy, which is the the
economic model of Denmark and Sweden and
other northern European countries. It's a
form of capitalism. It's a well-regulated.
Speaker 2: Capitalism where there's like
social democracy, there's social Democrats,
and then there's Democratic socialists,
socialists who would want a capitalist
society to become socialist. Inevitably,
it would be to. Cratic socialists.
So I guess in that sense, yeah,
I would. I'm for social programs. Yeah.
Speaker 1: No, listen, Carter, you're
sounding you're sounding pretty. At least in 2023
for the United States standard. You're sounding
sounding at minimum center left. And always good
to hear how things are going politically for you.
Speaker 2: Nice talking to you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There goes Carter
from Jersey. Sounding less and less
like a Republican every time we talk.